Okay. Next is Dr. Alleman, who's going to tell us about a personalized approach to treating
iatrogenic T-cell lymphoma from BCMA CAR-T. All right. Last talk. Thank you. Thank you again for
the invite. Today, I'm going to talk about CAR-T cell lymphoma that happened after silt-to-cell
therapy. As we all know and have heard throughout this whole conference, silt-to-cell is great.
It keeps patients, we might even be getting to a cure. However, there is one thing that has been
occurring, and that's the secondary adverse events. These are just five cases published
last year of secondary T-cell lymphoma cases that have happened after silt-to-cell, and they all
have commonalities. Most of them have a chip mutation, and most of them present with skin
tropism. And we at Mount Sinai also had a case. We had a case of a patient who came in, received
silt-to-cell, went into remission, and then around day 190, came in with facial lesions and
hypothermia. And we had a case of a patient who came in, received silt-to-cell, went into remission,
and had hypercutaneous imaging on PET scan. So we wanted to know what was it at the time and how do
we treat it? So the first thing we did was work it up. We found that histology was showing that it
was CD3 positive and lacked CD4 and CD8s. And more importantly, it actually, through flow cytometry,
had the CAR vector still in there. So it was a CAR-T T-cell lymphoma that showed the same thing
as the pathology. This was also present not only in the skin, but also was in the peripheral blood,
lymph nodes, and bone marrow. When we looked at the genetic profile, we ended up seeing that
this actually has an expansion of a previous ChIP-Tet2 clone, and there was a novel EZH2
clone that was present in this T-cell lymphoma. Additionally, the CAR itself had integrated into
the TIA1 gene. So we wanted to implement a personalized approach. The first thing we did
is we characteristically immunophenotyped it comprehensively. The first thing we found was
that it had CCR4. So we incorporated into the patient's regimen mogolizumab, and then we
actually did a high-throughput drug screening. So on the peripheral blood, we had a high-throughput
blood. We extracted some of those malignant CAR-T cells and then tested them with 179 different
compounds and found the compound that would be most toxic to the CAR-T cells, but left endogenous
T-cells relatively without cytotoxicity. We found that the best class of drug for this was
anthracycline therapies. So we combined this anthracycline therapy using liposomal doxorubicin
and gensitabine with mogolizumab, and the patient had a fantastic response. So in the blue,
you see the endogenous T-cells going down as the tumor malignant CAR-T cells start expanding in the
peripheral blood. But as soon as we start initiating the personalized therapy, the CAR-T
cells were gone from the blood. They were gone from the bone marrow and the lesions cleared up
in the face, and the endogenous T-cells bounced right back. And on the right, you see the imaging
showing the same thing where the patient entered a very good response. Not only that, he's been
in remission in myeloma and T-cell lymphoma for almost two years now. So this was a very
successful case, but we kept thinking, what drove it? What caused this pathogenesis of the T-cell
and the TET2 and EZH2 both play suppressive roles, and that chip mutations, like I said,
was common in other cases that we have seen. And TA1 is a suppressive gene as well that has
transcriptional modifications, inflammatory responses in T-cells. We wanted to know which
one was the driver of these three mutations that caused this T-cell lymphoma. So we aimed to test
it in the lab. We have a sample banked from the patient at the same time that we collected for
apheresis to send for Cilta-Cell, and we made lab-made CAR-Ts. And then this was done by our
postdoc, Ruja.
We started knocking out the main genes of interest here. So we knocked out TET2, EZH2, and TA1.
What we ended up seeing is that the proliferation was affected by these knockouts. So we started
doing combinations as well. The highest proliferative status that we saw from the
knockouts when we knocked out TET2 and EZH2, and that's in the yellow line in the graph.
But what we can tell is that the TET2 mutant actually itself also had a very high proliferative
advantage. So apart from proliferation advantage, we actually ended up seeing that
the phenotype of these knockout cells actually shifted as we introduced them. So the control
CAR-Ts in the first row, and then on the bottom, you see the TET2, EZH2 mutant. And you see that
it starts shifting to look like the malignant CAR-T cells that was in our patient. We see an
increase of CCR4, which we attribute to skin tropism as CCR4 is a skin-homing chemokine.
We see the PD1 increase, and we see a loss of CD7 that's actually present in the double mutant,
and I'm not showing it in the single mutants, but the single mutant, the TET2 knockout,
actually had the same phenotypic change. From there, we wanted to see, did it affect the
function? We know that the CAR-Ts in our patient actually were inert. So we ended up doing a
functional assay in which we combined these CAR-T cells with myeloma cells and then assessed the
cytotoxicity. The red bar is a control CAR-Ts that we made at the same time as a phoresis.
The tumor CAR-Ts are CAR-Ts isolated straight, the malignant CAR-Ts isolated straight from the
patient's peripheral blood. And then the other graphs on the other columns on the right are the
different knockdown cytotoxicity. And what you can appreciate,
is that the TET2 has the highest single knockdown reduction of cytotoxicity, while you get an even
greater augmented effect when you do the double knockout of TET2 and EZH2, indicating to us that
TET2 may have been the main driver, but EZH2 definitely did attribute to increased
inertness that we saw in the tumor CAR-Ts that were present.
And this is just a graph describing what the genomic characteristics of all the knockdowns
that we ended up seeing. The TET2, like I said before, it had a very big increase in CAR-T growth
on the DISH. It also increased the differentiation markers that we saw in our patients on the DISH,
in our patients' actual malignant CAR-T cells and had the significant loss of cytotoxicity.
We don't see much changes with the TIA1 knockdown, so maybe the actual integration itself didn't
provide a significant shift, but we think that the combination between the TET2 and EZH2 are the main
drivers that are causing this malignancy that we saw in our patients. So in conclusion, we report
a case where we had a patient with this adverse event that is rare, but it is something that we have to
deal with. And we implemented a personalized approach by not only using comprehensive
immunophenotyping, but also high-throughput drug screening. And our in vitro modeling does
indicate that the CHIP mutant that was expanded and the novel EZH2 loss contributed to the
malignant transformation by the increased proliferation, the change in the phenotypic
behavior that look more in line to what we saw in our patient's tumor, and in general,
reduction in functionality that we see that was present in our patient's tumor.
And this is just important because monitoring
CHIP mutations in CAR-T could allow for early detection and mitigation of these side effects.
And we had a piper, not talking about TET2, but in TP53 mutations in which we saw that
patients that had that were more likely to have MDS or AML as secondary malignancies. Thank you.